there are now more than 3 million cases
of the corona virus in this country
despite the surge the Trump
administration is pressuring schools to
fully reopen this fall ultimately it's
not a matter of if schools should reopen
it's simply a matter of how they must
fully open and they must be fully
operational the CDC is expected to issue
new guidance next week on how schools
should reopen now this comes after
president Trump slammed the agency on
Twitter calling its current guidelines
expensive and impractical mr. Trump also
threatened to pull funding from schools
that stay closed we spoke to some
teachers who say they are concerned
about the effectiveness of remote
learning but they are also worried about
safety I worry about you know teachers
that are immune compromised or live with
somebody that's immune compromised I
worried that if we can't provide
in-person instruction that some of my
students will be so incredibly behind I
think that while considering things like
their social and emotional growth are
incredibly important my students can't
learn if they're sick and I can't teach
them if I'm dead important to keep in
mind that ultimately it is up to States
to decide whether schools should reopen
not president Trump Margaret Spellings
was the Secretary of Education under
president george w bush he is now the
CEO of Texas 2036
that's a nonprofit focused on long-term
planning for the state she joins us now
from North Carolina good to see you
madam secretary we just heard that
teachers say listen - you can't learn if
they're sick I nice to see you kids
can't learn if they're sick and I can't
teach if I'm dead she makes a very good
point I don't know any politician or any
parent that doesn't want the kids to go
back to school August September so based
on what you're seeing and what you're
hearing and what you know do you think
it's safer for us to start planning to
send the kids back right now it can be
if we do it right and we think about all
the various contingencies that are
likely to crop up and all the
complexities if we communicate early and
often with our parent
about what those plans are and if we are
patient with each other about the need
for calling audibles along the way I
think our kids can be back in school in
some shape form or fashion and those are
gonna be hybrids sometimes in person and
sometimes remotely you know the
president calls the CDC guidelines he
calls them tough and expensive but when
it comes to children's health is there
any thing as being too tough or too
expensive there are still so many
unknowns as you know Madam Secretary
with this coronavirus well this is all
about risk management and and as has
been said and I agree with completely
there are downsides to having our
students out of school for so long
learning loss is real for students of
all kinds the functioning of our economy
and of families the ability for parents
to work I mean there are major downsides
to not having our students actively
engaged in their own learning and that's
what we need to balance but yes I mean
the cares Act had resources available my
own state of Texas is using those
resources to provide PPE and and various
other things cleaning materials and
supplies to schools so that they can
manage that risk as well as possible and
of course insisting on masks to the
maximum extent so it's a balancing act
will it be perfect it will not and
parents will need to be active
participants in the decision-making in
this regard but you've got the president
who to most people's knowledge doesn't
appear to have any medical training and
now he's slamming his own experts who
have the medical training and who are
looking at the science does that concern
you a little bit you know
what I'm seeing is that is that
educators County judges and County
health officials governor's are really
not looking to Washington for guidance
on this matter they know that every
single community is different their
health issues are different every single
person's a student and teacher their
issues are different and so this is
absolutely a you know locally driven
hurt most of the money for our schools
comes from state and local governments
the federal government is a minor
investor certainly can use a bully
pulpit to advance best practices and
provide clear communication but I think
parents are looking to their local
officials to understand the needs of
that community and that balancing act
and be a party to those decisions so you
think you're saying it's best to leave
it up to the state then to make their
own individual decisions the way it's
set up to do that's right
and they're the people who are paying
the bills and so honestly there's no way
for the present to withhold fundings
that have been a funding that's been
appropriated by Congress for particular
things that could they do that going
forward in a new piece of legislation
yes potentially yeah to add that
dimension to a really stressful
situation that's extremely complex is
just one more thing we shouldn't be
worrying about right now we need to have
certainty as much as possible around
funding around contingency planning and
around the health and safety and
educational needs of our students and
families so right now the guidelines
call for this face covering social
distancing staggered scheduling no
communal space if you were advising the
president and advising schools what do
you think would be the best course of
action here and parents who are
concerned saying I'm not sending my kids
back to school right now well I think
parents need options and I think
ultimately these are parental decisions
and if a parent elects not to send their
child into a situation where yes there's
more social distancing and the school
has done everything they can provided
masks not have the cafeteria open all
those things but if a parent is still
uncomfortable or if the family member or
that student has compromising conditions
then that parent ought to be able to
make the call to keep their child at
home home learning online or in some
sort of a hybrid and and I'm seeing
incredible creativity around the country
as as families and educators together to
meet those needs
but you know it's not without risk
in either direction but I think parents
are and will be an active part of the
the planning and as we go forward
alright secretary Margaret Spellings
very good to see this morning and may I
say I love your glasses I will be
calling thank you